okay good morning everyone we should
probably get started I wanted to say
that this is Jack Van Horn from the bb2k
training coordinating Center at the
University of Southern California and
I'm delighted to introduce our section
one lecture this morning on data
indexing and retrieval by dr. William
her shoes professor and chair of the
department of medical informatics and
clinical epidemiology at the Oregon
Health and Science University we're
delighted to have Bill here this morning
and we look forward to his presentation
bill stage is yours
okay thank you John is the is my voice
volume okay it's perfect thank you okay
well thank you for inviting me to to
give this lecture and I am honored to be
part of this course which is just a
further recognition of the importance of
data science and biomedical informatics
in biomedical research and and for NIH
if I get my slides to move here okay so
um today is um really an introduction to
this whole section and this the
following five weeks after today we'll
drill down into the topics under the
second bullet and I was asked to kind of
address this issue as a whole so I
thought it would step back and give the
big picture in an area that is derived
from information retrieval or IR or
search many of you know this is an area
I've been doing research for several
decades and as we transition from
looking to find documents towards
looking to find data there are some
issues that we need to address and make
some modifications of what we do so I
thought in this lecture that I would
first kind of give the big overview of
search
and drilling down into areas such as
content indexing and retrieval probably
some of this is familiar to you all and
certainly probably almost everyone
listening has done search and then the
way I decided to address the topics was
to give just a brief high-level overview
and then ask some questions that you
could think about when you actually
listen into those lectures in the coming
weeks a little bit more about myself as
John mentioned I'm chair of the
department of medical informatics and
clinical epidemiology here in the School
of Medicine at OHSU if anyone has any
questions feel free to email me I have a
website which actually has a link to a
PDF of these slides and the references
that I cite have also sent that to John
if they want to put it on their site as
well I also write a blog called the
informatics professor and I'm not a real
heavy-duty Twitter person but I do tweet
and follow things on Twitter I've also
written a book it's it's actually
getting a little a little aged but the
basic principles are still sound on
information retrieval which was actually
published in 2009 so in addition to
lecturing on this topic today I'm
actually hoping to demonstrate something
else which is related to the grant that
my group here at OHSU has from the bd2k
program where one of the I believe it's
up to about twelve or fifteen centers
funded to do curriculum development ours
is under the open educational resources
initiative and we received that grant X
a couple years ago and I give a link
here to our page which is slowly filling
up with the content that we're aiming to
develop so again I'll give an overview
of information retrieval introduce the
specific topics and then the secondary
aim is to actually demonstrate what one
can do with
open educational resources in fact
essentially what I've done for this
lecture is pull slides from two of our
modules one on information retrieval one
on ontology z' and then i've modified
them to fit this and that's the purpose
of open educational resources is for
people to be able to not only use the
materials to learn from but also to
teach and under a Creative Commons kind
of license so let me start then with
data and information retrieval I'll I'll
show you some figures that I think give
a perspective on what we're doing when
we're trying to do information retrieval
the process that now it's discovery and
then some of the challenges in the
modern era for information retrieval so
um I like to think I know that last week
dr. mucin talked about the life cycle of
data I actually have a similar this
figure actually comes from my book for
me to try to figure out what it is we're
retrieving when we're looking up
scientific information and now
increasingly data so most scientific
knowledge is generated through research
usually new research in this day and age
research can not only be things in labs
things in clinical trials but of course
reanalysis of data things like
systematic reviews and meta-analysis or
going into either biological or clinical
data and doing further analysis if we
want to publicize that research we write
up the results into a paper submitted
for publication - usually a journal or
conference proceedings goes through a
peer-review process it may be rejected
and you have to revise it and resubmit
and sometimes you get caught in that
cycle quite a bit but if you're
persistent and you have decent research
it'll eventually be accepted and then
you'll publish it typically in a journal
although that may be changing over time
when you do publish it there's a you see
some dotted line
here of things that that may happen so
you may actually have to relinquish
copyright that's a big issue that could
probably take an hour in and of itself
I won't address in today's talk your
work may make it into secondary
publications reviews textbooks things
like that and of course if it's if your
research is any good it will generate
new questions that need to be asked or
it will generate data that others may
want to further analyze these days
particularly biological like genomic
data tends to go into data repositories
less so clinical data though that will
be changing over time so historically
the focus of information retrieval has
been to look for those documents but now
of course there is the potential ability
to ability to actually to actually to
actually find the way I look at
information retrieval is as a funnel and
again this comes from my book where the
process of information retrieval is
where we really are searching over all
the literature like when we go to PubMed
and in the process we find some possibly
relevant literature with our search and
then we select what's definitely
relevant but of course we may want to do
more with that we may want to actually
do text mining on the descriptions and
the papers or we may want to get at the
tables or even ultimately to the data we
may want structured or actionable
knowledge that's more the domain of
information extraction and text mining
those processes usually make use of
natural language processing machine
learning other kinds of things the
information retrieval is I wouldn't call
it a solved problem but it's a problem
that there's a lot of widespread
commercialized solutions where as
information extraction text mining is
something that that is more starting to
emerge there there are some commercial
companies but there's also a lot of
research systems that do that as well um
so focusing in on the process of
information retrieval what were
ultimately aiming to find
his contents and I used that word
content deliberately to really cast the
net broadly anything from papers to
images videos and of course data we in
order to be able to find that content we
have to go through an indexing process
I'll talk about that in more detail in a
moment some way of basically generating
metadata data that describes data about
the content so when we have that
metadata we can then have users who are
seeking to retrieve things enter queries
and they enter queries in the metadata
and a search engine and you're I'm sure
you're all familiar with search engines
like Google and PubMed will connect will
will match that metadata from the
queries to what to the content so the
user can retrieve information retrieval
when I started working in this field in
the 1980s was something that you
oftentimes had to go to a librarian or
used to pay money for dial-up internet
or dial-up actually into the systems
themselves over time sharing networks
CompuServe AOL now of course some all of
us have computers and phones and
essentially essentially everyone has
used a search engine in fact some
browsers like Apple Safari will if
you're what you type into the URL box
doesn't match a URL it will throw you
into a search engine and people search
for health related information and the
latest statistics 71 percent of Internet
users meaning fifty-nine percent of all
adults search for information thirty
five percent using it for self diagnosis
and of course this is not just a u.s.
phenomenon it comes from the entire
world search is considered an integral
application many software packages have
search built into them enterprises
develop search capabilities across their
assets and so forth and we even have a
search engine optimization something
those of us doing research in the early
days never thought of where
people would be willing to pay money to
have their search results move up higher
in the rankings on fortunately some of
us have last names that are not that
common like h er SH so I have never had
to pay money to have my rankings
elevated if you type my name to Google I
come right at the top and just to show
you how mainstream I'm sure many if not
all of you have been to these search
systems PubMed and Google are probably
the PubMed for anything biomedical and
Google for anything the we also know
that access to information is really
part and parcel of Health and
biomedicine now in SEL back in 2003 said
that biology is becoming an information
science the the old days of capturing
things in your laboratory notebook is
being replaced by databases and
spreadsheets and all other kinds of
things we hear about pharmaceutical
companies competing for informatics
talent on the clinical side we have
clinicians trying to keep up with the
knowledge of their field where they're
in an era when there's about 75 clinical
trials and 11 systematic reviews
published each day and and searching is
ubiquitous it's even part of for those
who are familiar with electronic health
records the meaningful use regulations
and and one of the requirements is the
ability to do text search over
electronic health record notes so
searching is is pretty common but we
have some challenges we perhaps twenty
thirty years ago there was not that much
information online now we have the
opposite problem we're overloaded we
have challenges searching because there
are multiple ways to say the names of
diseases the names of genes symptoms
searching can be a challenge when
there's so much information out there of
course there's also the converse
problems where we have many words and
terms that have multiple meanings the
word cold
it can be the temperature cold the
disease cold and so forth or there was
just paper and I think it was nature
within the last few weeks about how or
maybe was plos but how spreadsheets can
mess up gene analyses because genes like
ap are - one are converted by things
like Excel into the date April first and
of course so APR - one has multiple
meanings and then this other issue again
which is a very interesting topic to me
and probably many of you but it's just
beyond the scope of today is how we
balance that open access making the
fruits of research most of which are
paid for by the government freely
available versus the real cost of
producing it and maintaining it so these
are some of the challenges will they say
I'm not going to solve all these
problems today so let me drill a little
further into some of the aspects of
information retrieval let me start with
content and then again I used that word
content in a real broad sort of way so
back in the 1960s 70s even into the
1980s networks were slow we mostly
connected by telephone modems
just didn't have that much capability so
most of the content we searched on was
abstracts and mostly of journal articles
but then as the technology improved the
network bandwidth improved the whole
system became more affordable for
individuals and organizations to connect
to we and these aren't really in time
wise order but they're they're sort of
we we then move to full text so instead
of the abstracts now we could put the
whole article online we can move things
like text books we could publish reports
and so those are predominantly
text-based
still the memory and bandwidth
requirements are modest but then we
start moving into hyper media where we
have web pages images sounds and videos
and so forth and the data the bandwidth
requirements and storage requirements
start to increase and then also the
development of structured collection
textbooks that are linked across each
other large databases
and so forth and so these the middle
bullet those content materials have been
increasing in size in fact we pretty
much take them for granted and then now
we move into the new era when we can no
longer just publish the results of our
research but we can publish our data and
the if you read the medical literature
or any other source there's
controversies about you know how readily
available should data be someone
pointing the term research parasites
which made a lot of people upset what
are the what are the issues behind
making data available I won't comment on
the economic or political issues but I
will comment on the technology and
informatics issues around data retrieval
let me um then talk so I talked about
content let me talk a little about
indexing and indexing is critical
because we need somehow to be able to
find the content that we're looking for
and this is where metadata comes in data
about data we assign metadata to content
items and we can do it in automated
fashions or using manual methods
automated systems things like Google
things like the word search in PubMed
will very easily pull out the words in
the records or the the documents and so
forth and we can assign measures to them
that allow us to rank the output any
undergraduate computer science student
can write algorithms to extract out the
words of a document it's a it's a known
relatively known thing to do
we've also since the beginning of things
like MEDLINE had manual indexing where
there are experts who in the case of
MEDLINE follow a protocol where they
assign terms from the medicals from from
a controlled vocabulary in this case
math
medical subject headings and they follow
a protocol where they look at different
parts of the article in a process that
takes about 15 to 20 minutes because
there's so many so they focus on things
like the introduction in the conclusion
and the figure legends and then they
assign anywhere from 5 to 10 mesh terms
and a few of them get designated as
central concepts there's other so those
are assigning subjects what the content
is about but there's other attributes we
might want for example we might want to
know the author I actually do a fair
amount of author searching oftentimes I
know I want to go find someone's paper
that was published in a certain place so
I answer their author name and in in
PubMed when you type two words together
and the second word only has one or two
characters it will try to map that into
an author we might want to know the
source the the journal that it came from
it was a report that's published by an
institution etc we might want to know
the publication type this is
particularly important well in a number
of places but one of the major ones is
with clinicians who are looking for
example to make an evidence-based
decision and use a randomized controlled
trial there's things like secondary
source and in the case of MEDLINE and
this is where we have linkage to gene
resources protein resources all the
other myriad of databases that are
available through the NLM the National
Library Medicine and other organizations
we may want to know the grant number
because we're for whatever reason and
then of course the location the
bibliographic databases in the old days
told us where to go into the library
stacks to to find the journal now they
the location gives us a URL or basically
with a digital a DOI a digital object
identifier that's converted into a URL
so right from the MEDLINE record we can
click a link and go to the publishers
website to retrieve the article and and
sometimes we run into paywalls and and
so forth but but at least there's a link
to where we can go get it we don't have
to go searching through the stacks and
the days of all
um a little bit more about mesh mesh
well all indexing vocabularies they're
usually consist of control terms they're
usually organized in a hierarchy I have
a figure on this slide that's basically
a vertical slice through a piece of mesh
started mesh has 16 trees Anatomy
diseases chemicals and drugs one of
which is diseases and you see I'm
basically traversing down the hierarchy
cardiovascular diseases vascular
diseases hypertension etc and all in all
there's about 26,000 terms in mesh and
then there is a number of synonyms so
you can stress the terms in different
ways and if you ever want to go look at
mesh there's a nice website that the NLM
keeps is basically a mesh browser onto
the retrieval side remember the purpose
of doing indexing is so we can retrieve
and there's really two kind of general
approaches that search systems use one
is the requirement for boolean operators
and or and not and helping you to narrow
your set or to express things in
different ways not is less frequently
used but sometimes we use it to filter
out certain things or what we see more
commonly is natural language systems
where we don't actually have to
explicitly type the boolean operators
although oftentimes things are done for
example in Google the default is to do
an and between all of the words that you
type into Google there's ways to
override that but that's Google's basic
function on the natural language sorry
the the boolean systems basically give
us sets things sources like PubMed will
sort them by reverse chronological order
with natural language systems we usually
get the results ranked and so when you
do a Google search or really any system
that uses natural language searching the
results will be certain will be sorted
sometimes by the word occurrence and
frequencies of words
common to what the user has entered and
what's in the content or the use of in
links which of course was popularized it
really was the basis of the Google
search engine and as part of the the
reason why it works so well in a in the
setting of the World Wide Web with
billions of documents how many pages
point to you and that's one of the
things that goes into how Google ranks
its results over the years they've had a
lot more and now it's all proprietary
but but the original feature of Google
was that PageRank algorithm that was
described by Brin in 1998 a few more
comments about metadata which is data
about data so it tells us what the data
items mean and we most there's different
types of metadata we've mostly been
talking about descriptive metadata that
enables us to discover or identify it
but there's also structural metadata
that describes how the work the data
itself is structured the fields that are
used and so forth and administrative
data on how its management how its
managed and this can include rights
management so who can access it when and
how and also how it's been preserved how
it's been archived and stored when we
talk about IR systems the the best
example is literature indexing and
annotation but metadata exists for
databases almost any kind of
computerized resource one final question
I'll just cover briefly is how do we
know how well we've done when we search
I actually I and many other people who
work in information retrieval always
very interested in this question and
have done research looking at it there's
a lot of questions we can ask if we want
to know how well a search is is a search
system used that we make available to
users are they satisfying a lot of the
research has focused on relevant
information how much relevant
information did they find another
question we may ask is did they complete
their desire
tasks and I've looked at that mostly
from the standpoint of clinicians over
the years when we're looking for
relevant information there's the
well-known measures of recall and
precision of recall being of the
proportion of materials out there that
are relevant to the proportion of
content where do we get back so
retrieved and relevant divided by
relevant and then precision is the of
what we actually retrieved how much is
relevant so retrieved and relevant /
retrieved and there's a whole bunch of
issues when you use these measures in
research and so I'll I won't go into
that detail but there's you can search
the literature and medicine computer
science for all kinds of work that's
been done in this area
so let me I'm hoping to leave a little
bit of time for questions and so what I
was going to spend the rest of the
lecture doing was going through the
topics of section one and again I'm
going to present it to you asking
questions and I know each of the
lecturers and the following five weeks
will will go into details and maybe this
for you could set the stage for what you
might want to hear when they go into
much more detail in each of these so the
next week's lecture is entitled finding
and accessing datasets indexing and
identifier so a lot of what I've been
talking about but focused on data
collections and there's a number of
emerging sites that that are basically
search engines for data now and I list
two here although I can think of many
more off the top my head but data site
was one of the first ones it's a way to
find data sets and data sight is not
limited to medicine it covers many
topics there's another one that's more
focused on medicine from the bio caddy
project which I believe this speaker
next week is from that project data med
org
let's you search for collections of data
and why would you want to find data
usually because you may be interested in
doing research with it you want to
replicate the results of a study from
the data that they collected and so
forth and so I think the question to
think about here is I most information
retrieval has been done with information
and as we move from information to data
are there any issues that become unique
it it turns out there are with with
datasets in terms whereas for example a
journal article is published and then
it's done maybe there might be an
erratum sometimes or perhaps it's even
retracted but by and large it becomes a
static document datasets might not
always be static they might have
snapshots at different times but those
are some of the things we need to know
when we're creating data retrieval
systems to set up and allow the searcher
to be able to search on those sorts of
attributes another issue or another the
second topic will be data curation and
version control data again data curation
can sometimes become a little more
challenging than say just journal
articles because datasets have a context
and they may grow or change but it's
important to remember that that data
doesn't exist in a vacuum
data gets collected when there's usually
some sort of experiment or observation
going on the only data in the dataset
that gets that is collected is that
which with which was collected and so
sometimes when people do experiments
they may not collect certain types of
data that actually could have been
collected or perhaps they just couldn't
they couldn't have been collected
because they didn't think about
collecting those things probably every
researcher has done at least one
experiment in their lives when they
think to themselves oh why
I measure this or that when we were
doing the experiment so the the figure
here it comes from the University of
California Merced website I was looking
for a good picture of research data
curation and I found this one and this
really highlights some the challenges of
when we do an experiment we we need a
data management plan in fact NIH grants
now require that and and there's a lot
of detail that goes into storage we we
collect the data we have to describe it
analyze it and eventually when we're at
least done with the initial experiments
we move on then to archiving the data
and publishing now historically we've
just archive
researchers have archived data in their
own files hopefully at least
electronically though that's not always
the case probably not that's a not not
so much anymore but oftentimes those
archives are private the the study is
published although increasingly
researchers have to publish their data
especially in the omics world less so in
the clinical world though we're seeing a
lot of conversation going on about that
and of course his research is done with
extractions of data from electronic
health records and other clinical data
sources not to mention all of the
personal devices wearables and stuff
that people have so lots of data and
then I guess actually usually the
research question comes at the beginning
of the study and I guess what's actually
meant here but well again when we get
data we then can ask new questions now
we always have to be careful because
again data was collected for a certain
purpose back to that issue of context
but we may have a new research question
and so then we search the data and pull
out the data elements we need and reuse
them and of course we need to keep an
eye to reproducibility so if we go
through
cycle again with a new research question
we have to archive the data in a way
that we can reproduce the analysis that
we've done with the data so when you
hear the lecture on data curation in
version control you can think about
again how that how the data are
described and kept up to date another
the third topic you'll hear in this
series is on ontologies and this is
actually another example of pulling some
materials from our resources in our open
educational resources so this figure
comes from one of our modules that's
authored by melissa handle some of you
know who does a lot of work in ontology
x' so in case you don't know what an
ontology is as its defined in our module
and it's defined similarly elsewhere a
formal conceptualization of a specified
domain so clearly the terms need to be
defined sometimes people call things
like mesh and other controlled
vocabularies and ontology I think the
purists would actually argue that
they're not mesh is a fine medical
vocabulary a collection of a
comprehensive collection of terms that
are used to describe what's in the
medical literature but an ontology
structures the domain so you understand
the relationship so for example you see
here that we're looking at certain types
of neural cells and those cells are our
child or more refined from the ones
higher in the diagram but there's a
certain type of cell so the hippocampal
astrocyte
is capable of certain things and from a
different part of the ontology one that
in fact this is from the gene ontology
describes specific functions and so the
hippocampal astrocyte is capable of
those
it also may have some unique parts and
it's also part of organs so for example
it's part of the brain or also part of
the hippocampus which is part of the
brain and then there's some further
refinements so in an ontology the
relationships between all the terms are
defined and this not only organizes the
data but it allows us to make logical
inference we if if for example a
hippocampal astrocyte is a cell we there
are certain attributes of cell that can
be inherited down the hierarchy that we
can infer and and this enables us to do
more sophisticated data queries on
ontology z' can be complex and but they
they provide a much richer description
and so the questions you might ask with
ontology is how we can optimally index
and then do retrieval using ontology so
when we're looking for data but not only
for data can we use these also for
looking for literature and other kinds
of things if they've been indexed using
an ontology um the the week that follows
will be talked on metadata standards
there are many metadata standards to
choose from that sometimes they
duplicate each other which can be a
problem but often times they're
different because the tasks that the
metadata is put to is is different
there's actually a standards body the
International Organization for
Standardization Allah standards body has
standards for many many things one of
which is metadata their standards for
metadata repositories and other sorts of
things in the information retrieval
arena there are a number of metadata
standards the the MEDLINE record when we
search PubMed or there's other ways to
search MEDLINE the the elements the
fields in that MEDLINE record are
metadata
elements so the the author names the
title the mesh terms the secondary
source identifier all those things are
part of the metadata MEDLINE is
basically a collection of metadata
records for the medical literature
another metadata standard some of you
may be familiar with is Dublin core
metadata Dublin core metadata got its
start in the relatively early days the
world wide web in the 1990s it
originally
well actually still consists of 15
fields that are actually have some of
them have analyzed what's in MEDLINE so
the Creator the name of the resource the
URI which maps to the URL there's a
field called subject there's also a
field called rights that that that lists
the the rights management in terms of
who can access it and Dublin core
metadata has been extended really built
on top of by many many groups one of
which is data sight which I've already
mentioned they have a metadata for each
data source and their their system for
metadata builds on top of the dublin
core and then also groups like bio caddy
that map among a variety of metadata
standards with the focus on biomedical
data
so whereas MEDLINE has that focus on
biomedical literature dublin core had
the focus originally on web resources
mainly HTML pages but expanding to other
things biocad a is focus on biomedical
data so the question one of the
questions you might ask in that talk is
what approaches to metadata are optimal
for data indexing all the kinds of
things we might want to ask about data
resources when we're trying to retrieve
them and then of course how do we build
retrieval pages and the the da
data was that data meadow argh sorry is
is one approach and and what I know it's
a work in progress and what fields do
they need to add what search
capabilities and so forth on the the
final topic in in this section is
provenance and data provenance is
important basically data provenance what
is it it's it's where your data come
from and whenever I talk about data
provenance I always like to give an
example and so a few years ago some
clinical informatics colleagues and I
published the paper on some of the
challenges with using clinical data from
electronic health records in research
and just a number of caveats in fact
that's the net title of the paper
caveats for using clinical data in
research and provenance is one of the
big issues and and I think this will be
an example and there's analogous
examples from laboratory experiments and
so forth but a simple question we might
ask when we have a clinical data source
is a patient on a medication are they
taking the medication well there's
actually multiple ways that that that's
expressed and we really need to
understand each one and also the
limitations because sometimes the
physician might just write I'm putting a
patient on this medication but there
might not be an order or a prescription
for it
so once the order is made though then
the data gets sent to a pharmacy either
in the hospital or if it's an outpatient
to a community to pharmacy in the
community but again there there's not a
hundred percent of prescriptions that
make that journey of course they end up
in the pharmacy do does the patient
actually get the prescription filled
and then actually did they take the
medications and in the hospitals you
have things like medication
administration records and then also
when these days when patients come back
to hospitals we often do a process of
medication reconciliation
so the point of this is to really show
that there's many truths and I put
truths in quote for whether or not a
patient is on a medication and that can
be really important if we're doing a
research study where we're trying to
process the data that's an electronic
health record so and certainly any reuse
of data must take provenance into
account so I'm sure that those of you
who are more biologically inclined can
can come up with examples like the one
I've given here how did we really how do
we know what the truth is how do we know
where the data comes from and so when
you're asking when you're listening to
the lecture on data provenance you can
ask things like how do we best describe
the provenance that's in datasets so at
this point I'm going to continue I'm
going to we wanted to leave some time
for questions and I'm happy to answer
any questions as I understand it people
can either raise their hands or
electronically or type questions into
the box thank you Bill
so there's a couple of questions that
are in the box that somebody has asked
about they're asking about the storage
and retrieval of experimental data also
are there any standards or common
structures like ef5 and how does this
relate to open data sharing yeah you
know I have to admit I'm not an expert
in storage of biological data I do know
that that probably that area's more
developed than storage of things like
clinical trials data which they
sometimes just be in very ad hoc kinds
of ways so I would that question
especially on the specific data storage
I would probably need to defer to to
someone and and and maybe one of the
lectures in the coming week would be
able to answer that
yeah there was also the question about
how this all relates to open data
sharing in issues yeah sure
well I think that open data is actually
really in some way in most ways really
separate from how you store the data
when data you know becomes open the
question of course is how open it is is
it just sitting there freely available
on the internet or do do you have to
file a request with the originator of
the data if there's potentially
identifiable data in there on people do
you do you have to go through some sort
of IRB process I I think it all depends
you know I think we I'm an advocate of
open data but I also understand that we
need to protect researchers who you know
create the data and know the context of
it they should be willing to share it
but they also have some interest in
getting the most out of it and then also
when we start to get into data on people
you know especially when we start
massively sequencing genomes and if we
don't have ways to keep that data
private and de-identified we have to be
careful for those things there's
actually a number of studies that it's
been shown how you can read sometimes
depending on what data you have reaiiy
denta fide people from so-called
de-identified data sets we also looks
like they'll we have a library
scientists out there and so a couple of
them have asked questions about our
librarians and library scientists being
included on data management teams and
should they be and also how does the
ontological structures that you've
described how do they link in with like
mesh for example sure I certainly
believe that librarians bring important
skills to the the groups that manage
data I
I don't think that researchers always
realize the you know you always hear
stories about researchers who lost their
old data or they can't figure out what
it what the data was and that's why it's
important to to bring those with the
kind of expertise that librarians have
to make sure that your data is
documented well that that the you know
metadata is there to define what your
data elements are so so that you have
good definitions and can go back to your
data in the future through the metadata
to remember exactly what what the data
is so there's absolutely a role for
those sorts and the second question
again was oh is how to do the
ontological structures that you've
described how might they Lincoln with
mesh sure they you know certainly the
you know like I showed you the ontology
you know of the cells and the certain
neural cell types the individual items
in the ontology should be in controlled
terminology sets like mesh or other ones
mesh mesh tends to go into more details
around diseases it tends to have more of
a focus on the biomedical literature but
there's other controlled vocabulary sets
so the the terms in an ontology should
be from from a controlled vocabulary set
and then if something say indexes the
literature like the way that mesh does
that that you could then map even though
mesh doesn't capture those relationships
but you would at least be able to map
from the terms and of course there's
another important resource here that
that we should mention which is the
unified medical language system or umls
that's been developed by the National
Library of Medicine on the umls is a
collection of terminologies
and there are basically synonym linkages
across vocabulary so if you find a term
in one controlled vocabulary and it
occurs in another you can use the umls
mehta thesaurus to map across those
terminology sets and so so so again the
the terms in an ontology should
definitely be from a controlled
vocabulary if they're not they should
become part of one great we had a
question about that you had mentioned
that you'd like to see more clinical
data being deposited into open
repositories and could you possibly
speak about the timeframe that you might
see this happening in and which
stakeholders might drive it and also
maybe comment about how it so doing
would help to encourage reproducibility
avoid this representation of data and
the like yeah well you know I you know I
certainly support the notion that the
data should be open and people should
have access to it especially data that's
being collected on projects that are
funded by the government by our tax
dollars I do though think we we need to
be careful and so there probably needs
to be a process I know for example in
some of the NLM databases that that have
the genome-wide Association studies
there are processes where you have to
apply to get the data the the the two
things I think we need to be careful I
don't think that researchers should be
able to horde their data but researchers
know a lot of the context of the
experiments that they run they spent a
lot of time and effort collecting the
data so they should certainly be able to
you know get the most out of the data
when it's first generated the
publication so certainly there should be
some period where there they are they
have say a total purview over the data
um then you know when it's a reasonable
amount of time and you can argue how
long you know six months twelve months
some say things like five years which is
probably too long then it should go into
some controlled release sort of format I
think especially going to be true as we
do
more things with patience you know with
people that identify them their genome I
know that there are some methods and I'm
no expert in them to partially D
identify gene variants and things like
that I mean but the reality is is that
there will be and people have shown you
can even the the famous study by Latanya
Sweeney where she was able to identify
the governor of Massachusetts in a
health database by purchasing the voter
registration rolls for the city of
Cambridge Massachusetts and and
connecting him through his I think it
was zip code gender and date of birth so
I think I think we need to so data
should be open but it should be released
in a way that's controlled and III think
there's a role for higher bees here to
approve these sorts of things because
there is always the you know another
potential someone you know doing an
analysis that that it is not really
justified based on the context of the
data and getting different results I
think there's still issues to be worked
out especially when we start releasing
data that's originally collected by
humans but I certainly support the
notion of doing that there was a
question about what does the lack of
consistent ontologies across all the
medical domains from practice to
research and back again
does that come at a cost to the to the
country it could you comment on that
yeah well I can I can answer the
question simply by saying yes but just
to make some additional comments yes you
know I think and you see this now in the
clinical informatics world where I spend
most of my time you know so we've
finally after after all these years have
achieved widespread adoption of
electronic health records unfortunately
they don't easily talk to each other
even even when they can exchange the the
bits the the electrons of the data they
they don't readily exchange the meaning
and
and it'll probably we'll never achieve
perfection on this because different
humans interpret different things about
patience and so forth but but a big part
of the problem and and the Office of the
National Coordinator for health IT has
recognized this now is that we haven't
really adhered to standards standards on
the elements and medical records
standards on the terms that we use to
describe diseases lab tests and so forth
and there are standards out there
they're not all perfect but they they go
a long way so I think that we need to
encourage standards and there's
standards processes that individuals who
really care about them can get involved
but we need to encourage standards in a
way that that we call something the same
thing or at least that there's an
identifier we might have different ways
of describing it different synonyms for
it but that they ultimately mapped back
to some identifiers we should do that on
as much as possible there there may be
some things that change over time I
commonly give an example when when I was
in medical school there was no hepatitis
C or D or however many different types
of hepatitis there now was all non-a
non-b hepatitis and so term
terminologies change over time and we
need to model the the adaptation of
terms but but yes we should strive to
use standards whenever we can it should
be required by the the government the
funders the journals etc so that we
achieve as much use of it as possible
well with that point the another
question was would you care to kind of
predict or guess at the chances that in
the future a literature will become pre
indexed with people maybe pre
registering their studies against
particular data ontology or with
particular methods yeah certainly that
possibility exists I mean in fact for
clinical trials now they have to be
registered in clinical trials gov and
certainly people who
awarded you know NIH grants have that
they know what they're studying so they
could do that free indexing of course
you know sometimes with studies you have
unexpected finding so I don't know that
the indexing would would totally stop
the before the study was completed but
that's certainly a possibility and and
you know you can go search databases
like clinical trials.gov
to find you know studies on specific
diseases and treatments and so forth
let's see do you have any other
questions that are good ones I'm sure
there's a bunch here and would be
delighted to share them with you bill
maybe you can reach out to the to the
askers at a later time but it looks like
sorry yeah yeah sure I'd be happy to do
that you know we can even you know make
it publicly available I can type in the
answers yeah that would be wonderful
well let me kind of bring things to a
close here and thank bill for a
fantastic lecture in our second of our
data science seminar series once again
let me apologize to anybody who had some
difficulty getting in initially as it
might be clear we had a peak of 511 of
you and as a consequence we had to make
sure that we could upgrade and
accommodate everybody so we had to
update our URL the best way to find the
information is to go to wwg to you org
slash data science seminars and follow
the instructions there and so this a
GoToWebinar site will be the site we
always come back to so please spread the
word and come back and we'll see you
again next week so thank you very much
everyone have a great day